simple now the black rook is going to  come in and deliver the final blow soon  yeah just a great technique  and blitz that's all you need to do  just get rid of your opponent's final  hopes and  and magnus is leaning back he's ready to  resign like can give a check max pawn  can give a check or you can get the  queens off the board  yeah it's in the final throws this game  another queen check is going to come the  black rook is going to join the action  next move  here it comes  and that must be it yeah white can give  one check or blacking hides and  i think we're going to see magnus resign  no he's got a little wear  still still fighting fighting but now  they come off  he's going to resign everything okay  prague takes another win  what a game  it's over prague takes the first blitz  game he takes the lead in the tie breaks  with a draw or win in the second blitz  game well he will win